in the United States thousands of people
are gathering in Tulsa Oklahoma for
President Donald Trump's first campaign
rally in more than three months the city
has a history of racial tensions and
there are fears that Trump's visit could
spark violence the date of the event is
also being criticized coming just a day
after
Juneteenth a day marking the end of
slavery in the u.s. in several cities
across the u.s. demonstrators toppled
Confederate monuments in public spaces
including a statue of General Albert
Pike in Washington DC in North Carolina
a Confederate statue was hung on a
traffic light before being removed by
police the dismantling of the
controversial monuments came amid
otherwise peaceful Juneteenth gatherings
and rallies commemorating the end of
slavery in the u.s. but president Trump
responded by tweeting that the police
weren't doing their job the president's
original choice of yesterday's historic
date for his campaign rally sparked such
a large outcry that it was postponed by
one day president said he was coming on
June 19 didn't know it was your deed day
but even more controversial than the
choice of date is the president's choice
of location Tulsa Oklahoma the city is
the site of the worst incident of racist
violence in US history in 1921 the
city's Greenwood district a bustling hub
of successful black owned businesses
known as black Wall Street was razed to
the ground by white mobs 300 black
people were killed 99 years later many
Tulsa residents are still affected by
racism they say Donald Trump is not
welcome not far from the Greenwood
district Trump supporters have been
camped out for days thousands are
expected to attend the rally on Saturday
black lives matter protesters have also
planned their own rally
and fearing the potential for violence
the city has imposed a curfew around the
venue for Trump's event in a town still
bearing the unhealed wounds of the past
locals have a message for President
Trump
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm joined now by correspondent
Stefan Zeman's who is in a Tulsa outside
the arena where the rally is scheduled
Stefan what is going on there right now
okay yeah we're standing in downtown
Tulsa Oklahoma and here to my to my
right is a security fence bailed up and
right be it right there on this side to
the camera can show you this it's
actually the checkpoint which lets those
hundreds of Trump supporters who have
already gathered here in a few hours
getting closer to the arena I have to go
through some security checks but as you
can see right down right behind me here
there's hundreds of people here now and
the crowd is growing by the minute and
they're quite excited quite excited to
see their president they say some of
them dozens of them have camped out here
all night all week so to speak and now
that's their day and they're very
excited so far everything is fairly
peaceful the occasional very patriotic
chant yeah and that's the situation so
far there will be thousands more coming
here that's for sure well sure and
listen I wanted to ask you about because
you know Donald Trump has given I'd say
dis concordant messages on how to deal
with the corona virus whether or not his
followers were following the health
guidelines but we can see our reviewers
can see right behind you they're pretty
pretty close to each other well let me
step aside from the camera here to
decide do you see there's nothing social
distancing is just right out of the
window nothing happening like this
nobody's social distancing here and a
lot of people are not wearing masks and
we talked to some there really think
Kovic 19 a lot of them think Keurig 19
is a over or B never was every actually
existent they declined to to understand
or say they for them covert 19 was never
a problem will be never a problem is
probably over hopes so that's a little
bit surprising a disconcerting actually
I have to say because of course wearing
a mask is protecting
the other person right not just yourself
the other person well this falls on deaf
ears here in this grout yeah well
precisely I think they're people around
the world have been caught that message
police though they're in Tulsa are they
worried about clashes between anti and
pro Trump people of course they are not
right now at this hour but the late of
the day and into the evening when the
rally actually starts 7:00 p.m. local
here in Tulsa there will be even more
law enforcement on the streets you see
the security fence here and the National
Guard deployed 250 of them in Tulsa
actually and right behind the camera
they are camera they are a few you can't
just see that then this is all a Secret
Service FBI Oklahoma Bureau of
Investigation Metropolitan Police
Sheriff's Department and I could go on
and on and on there's lots of law
enforcement here and yes there are
concerns that protesters black lives
matter protesters who are scheduled to
protest is two miles away on Detroit
Street that this will cause some
friction or maybe even violence I
wouldn't go there and say like this is a
done deal there will be violence but it
is of course possible
it's very emotional here people are very
emotional those people here and of
course black lives matter protesters are
and yeah it could go any way mm okay
well let's hope nothing happens in any
case or manage difference even sits on
the ground in Tulsa Oklahoma thanks very
much